you created this 365-day like stock rsi
um over a 30-day net change of illiquid
supply
that is like an alphabet soup of things
to say explain what this metric is and
then
it looks like right now uh it's starting
to show some pretty interesting things
especially when you compare it to what
it's uh shown us over the past
yeah for sure um the name is definitely
a mouthful like some of the stuff just
sounds like
really complex it's really not um what
this basically is is
a way to kind of track the the
underlying
supply shock in the market because in my
opinion that's
that's what drives bitcoin up to have
these big
price rallies is um you know you have
this wave of supply shock
and then the speculators come in and
ride that wave up and and you know take
the reins of it
and and push it up further on the
speculative premium
um and so like when you go back and look
at bitcoin's history i also threw in
the newsletter we did this week an
example from the you know 2017-2018 um
that time frame um and what you see is
kind of you know at the beginning of the
bull market
um you know well i should i should start
here at you know in the bear market
you had a capitulation event and then
going into the bull market
um you have the supply uh supply shock i
like to think of as a supply squeeze
kind of just because it sounds cooler
but that's what really propels
us into that main phase of the bull
market and then on the back end of that
um
you see you know supply becomes liquid
again um
and so for anybody who's not familiar
basically when i'm saying a liquid or
liquid
um the way you can think of this is like
um the the
coins moving to like entities on the
blockchain that have a very low
or high um spending behavior so
liquid and and glass that also has
something called highly liquid which is
like a way to look at it even further
um have like extremely high spending
behaviors so these coins are in and out
all day
spec these are speculative traders right
then you have liquid coins which
are you know are in and out of fair
amount and then you have illiquid and a
liquid are the way i like to think of it
as the strong hands right um
these are the people that take in a lot
of coins never really sell them these
are the long-term investors that are
kind of the
the um you know concrete foundation of
of
of bitcoin so um you know kind of
analyzing their behavior i think has a
lot of signal to it and you know these
are
the these um indications that that you
get from this metric
aren't um you know you don't get them
often but when they do come
they have a very high reliability um and
so what we have now
is you know we had this big capitulation
event in the end of may
a bunch of coins became liquid um that
were previously registered as strong
hands
and and so what you've had since then
it's just this really strong
reaccumulation
um and so like in this broader context a
broader context
we've actually reached um what i what
i've used for this metric as
a buy signal where we fully made the
rounds from you know a full capitulation
below this rsi
and now we're back above it so to me you
know just seeing not only that that
we're in a buy signal but
um the rate of change from that cell
from that capitulation to this new
to this new buy signal is just flash is
really is really
um you know quite incredible um going
going back in bitcoin's history we
haven't really
seen anything like this aggressive per
se like we actually you know obviously
like i said you know we see these supply
shocks every you know every bull run
um but but nothing on on um
on this scale of in terms of momentum
even even looking back to last year
which was you know
it's still still a really strong wave
but yeah
this has pretty much just been vertical
accumulation since may
and so when you look at things like
exchange balances it looks like again
uh people are buying bitcoin on the
exchanges and they're just
taking them off almost as fast as they
possibly can is that accurate
yeah um so the the exchange flows are
are something that i think a lot of
people are familiar with now um
you know the way that the premise here
is that you know when coins are being
moved on to exchanges
um they're being sold um you know when
they're being moved off exchanges
they're going into some kind of like
custodial service or cold storage
not you know to be held um and so this
is something that you know a lot of
analysts have been following
for the for you know the early mid part
of this bull run up until kind of mid
april
um you know you just had coins just
getting ripped off of the exchanges
um and so you know in in mid april all
of a sudden you had like
you know between then and and uh and
march i mean i'm sorry in uh may 19th
you had like 145 000 coins that came out
to exchanges
and so you know that was obviously
highly bearish because you had a lot of
people moving those coins onto exchanges
to be sold so that was like kind of an
indication that
you know we were going to need this kind
of prolonged um re-accumulation phase
because a lot of coins had been sold
but since then since since may 19th
we've kind of just been
grinding sideways bearish um well i
shouldn't say sideways bear sideways
down which is actually bullish
for this indicator because it's saying
the exchange balances are going down
um but this week we've got this really
large down drop
anybody who is on twitter by the way um
might have seen yesterday that um
there were these huge reported outflows
and um i left that data out this this
data is only going up to thursday i left
the i mean
only up to wednesday i left the thursday
data out
just because um some some of those
transfers were internal it just hasn't
been picked up by last notes heuristics
yet
so i just you know wanted to just be on
the safe side and just leave that data
out but
um even even excluding that um which is
showing like
like a ridiculous you know uh signature
on the chart that's why i just left it
out because you know
there's no way that that that's true it
has to partially be internal
um you know it's we're still seeing
really strong accumulation um in terms
of
the exchange flows as well